All right. Hey everyone, welcome
back. This is people hear me okay.
All right. So if as usually you can
take a second to enter your, uh,
id so we know who's here.
Um,
so today's lecture will be a
choose your own adventure lecture.
Um,
so I think you know,
by now you've learned a lot about the
technical aspects of building learning
algorithms. And then in the third
course, in the third set of modules,
you saw some of the principles
for debugging, learning
algorithms and how they,
as you use these tools in order to be
efficient in how you build a machine
learning application. What I want to
do today is a step through with you,
a moderately complicated
machine learning application.
And,
um,
throughout all of today's lecture I'm
going to step you through a scenario and
then as you to kind of
choose your own adventure.
Because if you are working on this
project, what are you going to do, right?
And to give you more of that
practice in the next, um,
what are in a bit that we
have a on thinking through
machine learning strategy.
Um, and you know, I've, I've
seen in so many projects, uh,
they're there sometimes things that a
less strategically sophisticated team will
take a year to do.
But if you're actually very strategic
and very sophisticated in deciding what
you will do next,
very how the drive the project forward.
I've seen many times that what a
different team will take to do.
Maybe you could do it in a
month or two and you know,
if you are trying to read a
research paper or build a business,
I've got the product,
the ability to drive a machine learning
project quickly gives you a huge
advantage and just,
you know,
you're making much more efficient
use of your life as well. Right. Um,
so for today I'd like to, uh, uh,
I'm going to pose a scenario, post a
machine learning application and say,
all right, I mean, you are the CEO of this
project. What are you going to do next?
So, but I'd like to have today's
meeting be quite interactive as well.
So can they get people to sit in
groups of two and ideally three or so,
maybe plus minus one. And, um,
tried to sit next to someone that you
don't work with all the time. Uh, so,
so if a Sydney sitting next year,
best friend,
I'm glad your best friend
is in the class review,
but go sit through someone
else because I think, um,
I've done this multiple times and
the discussions that he, Richard,
you talk to someone that
you don't know super well.
So as you take a second and introduce
yourself and just your neighbor,
I guess.
So the example I want to go through
today is actually a continuation of the
example I described briefly, uh, uh, in,
in the last lecture I us a building
a speech recognition system, right?
So remember I briefly,
I'm motivated this a trigger word,
wake word or trigger word
detection system last time where,
you know, uh, right, I,
I actually had both an Amazon
echo and Google home, uh,
but you know,
is this a lot of work to configure these
things to turn on and off your light
bulbs. Um, and so if you
can build a chip, uh,
to sell, to say, a lamp
maker to recognize, uh,
phrases like, you know, let's say
we call the Lamp Robin, right?
Then you can recognize phases like
Robin's her in the [inaudible], right?
Robin turned off and he kept that little
switch to give this thing different
names were called robbers or
leaner or allies or somethings.
You can also lean air turned on the,
turned off his gift to give you a lamp,
a name, and just say, Hey,
Robert turned on right.
So rather than detecting different
names and turn on and turn the off,
I'm just going to focus on just
for the technical discussion,
I'm just going to focus on the
phrase Robin turned on. Uh,
but it's kind of the same problem and
we need to solve like four times to give
it to names or to turn on and turn off.
So I'm going to abbreviate Robert,
turning on this Rto rights.
If you want to call your name Roberts,
and I'm a tell you lamp to turn
on. Um, I think it was inspired by,
well,
Isaac Asimov wrote these alums,
robotic novel C's and all this
robots name started with r.
So maybe our robot turn on. Um, and so,
uh, let's see. So let's see that, um,
you are the new CEO of a small startup
with fie persons are and you go is the
building is to build a circuit.
Oh,
actually your goal is to build a learning
algorithm that can recognize this race.
Robert turned on,
uh,
so that when someone buys this lamp and
they say Robert's in the on the lamp can
turn on, right? And just focusing on the
task of building and then you know, to,
to, to be CEO of this thought. They've
used to do a lot of things, right?
I need to figure out how to
do the embedded circuitry.
You figure out who the land
Meeker's the sales journey.
So there's all that stuff.
But for today,
let's just focus on the machine
learning aspect of it. Um,
and so my first question to
you is very open ended is, but,
and this is the life of the CEO,
right?
You wake up one day and you just
got to decide what to do. Um, but,
so my first question to you is, an open
ended question is, uh, you're the CEO,
you're going to show up
at work, uh, you know,
tomorrow in your startup office and you
want to build a learning algorithm to
detect the face Robert turned on
for this application, right? So, um,
so my question is what are
you going to do? Right?
So take a take a minute to answer
that by yourself first. No, don't,
don't discuss your neighbor yet,
but you know,
you're going to show
up in your office and,
and you're going to start working on this
engineering problem to build a neural
network to do this. So, uh, and, and do
this as yourself, right? Don't, don't,
don't pretend that Ya'll,
this hypothetical, whatever,
a startup CEO of 10 minute, $10 billion
to spend on whether it was just do this.
See, yeah, I, but I, I don't think
this is a terrible style of idea. I, I,
this is not the best idea,
but I think this could work.
So you actually welcome to do this,
but let's say you decide to do this
and you go into your office tomorrow,
what do you do? Right? Once you take, um,
why don't you take let's say two minutes
to enter an answer, then we can do,
you can discuss in fact,
I think of, yeah. Yes.
One thing I really like about answer
sheet the readers because the Singlish
usher upon, right? Um, in fact, when
you're suddenly a new project, um,
uh, uh, and I think, um, uh,
it's not the only project
like that assuming you've
not worked in trigger words,
it's action before,
you know,
reading research papers or reading code
and get hub or reading blog posts and
this problems as you're very good way
to quickly level of fuel knowledge. Um,
and I think that, you know,
it, it turns out that, um, uh,
in terms of your exploration
strategy, right? Um,
I want to describe to you how
I read research papers. Um, uh,
which is,
so this is not a good way
to review the literature,
which is if the x axis is time and
the vertical axis is research papers,
where some people will do is find the
first research paper and read that until
it's done and then go in and find
a second research paper and V.
Dot until it's done.
And then you can find the third
research paper printers for this is very
sequential way of um,
meeting research papers.
And I find it the more strategic way to,
to go through these reasonables is
everything ranging from blog posts, um,
lots of good medium articles
and they explain things very,
it's our research papers. Um, right.
Good hog is if you use a
parallel exploration process
where this does actually
what it feels like when I'm doing research
on where I'm trying to learn about a
new few of them, not that expanded, right?
So after she's done a lot of
work on trigger words detection,
but if it hadn't worked on this before
then I would probably be fine, you know,
three papers.
So again,
it's classes as time and virtually acids
as different papers and um, you know,
read a few papers kind of in parallel
at a surface level and skimmed them.
And based on that you might decide to
read that one in greater detail and then
to add other papers that you started
screaming and maybe finding another one.
Do you want to read in great detail and
into gradually add new papers to your
reading lists? A and B, some to
confusion and some not to completion. Um,
you know, I was actually chatting
with um, uh, uh, one of my friends,
a PDRP former students at Berkeley who
mentioned that he was wanting to learn
about a new topic and he, he was, uh,
he told me he was compiling a reading
list of 200 research papers they want to
read. That sounded like a lot.
You rarely read 200 papers,
but I think if you read 10
papers, you have a basic
understanding. If you read 50,
you have a pretty decent
understanding of read like a hundred.
I think you were very
good at understanding, uh,
of of a few but often does
this time well spent I guess.
Um, and, uh, some other
tips, again, this is,
I'm really thinking if you really are
CEO of this startup and this is what you
want to do, what advice
would I give you? Um, uh,
when you're reading papers are other
things to realize? Uh, one is that, uh,
some papers don't make sense, right?
And this fine, uh, uh, you know,
even ivy some papers I just go, nope, I
don't think that makes sense. Uh, and,
and it's not uncommon for us to
find papers from a decade ago that,
and we learned that half of it was free
and the other half of it, you know,
was really talking about things that were
not that important. So it was okay. Uh,
authors, you know, usually
papers of technically accurate,
but often what they thought was important.
Like maybe an author thought that using
bash them was really important for this
problem, but it just turns out not to
be the case that that happens a lot.
But that happens sometimes.
And I think the other tactic that I see
Stanford students sometimes not using
now is talking to experts,
including contacting the authors.
So when I read the paper, um, uh, I don't,
I don't bother the authors unless I've
actually like tried to figure it out
myself.
Right?
But if you actually spend some time
trying to understand the paper and if it
really doesn't make sense
to you, uh, uh, uh, is, is,
is okay to email the authors and see if
they respond and, and people are busy.
Maybe there's a 50% chance of responding.
And that's okay because it takes you five
minutes to write an email and there's
a 50% chance to get back to
you. That could be time pretty
well spent. Uh, uh, but,
but don't, don't, don't bother people
on this. You tried to do your own work.
I actually got a lot of emails from,
you know,
high school students that do not feel
like they've done their own work.
And I just write and then, Eh, so, so
just don't, don't, don't bother people.
And as you've actually tried to,
um,
cool. So after, um,
looking at the literature
and having a base,
maybe downloading a open
source implementation or
getting a sense of an avenue
where they try,
oh,
it turns out they trigger words detection
literature is actually one literature
where there isn't consensus on this is
a good algorithm does is a bad algorithm
where despite all the trigger words
or wake word detection systems that,
you know, some of you may use
already, uh, there, there,
there isn't actually a
consensus in the, in, in,
in their research me today on like,
this is the best average try. Um,
but so let's say that, um,
you've read some papers,
downloads some open
source and plantations,
and now you want to start
training your first system, right?
The last time we talked about this,
we talked a little bit about how much
time you would spend to collect data.
And you know,
we said we spend a small amount of time,
spend like a day or
maybe two days at most.
So collect your first data set
to start training up a motto. Um,
but my next question to you is a,
what data would you collect?
Right? Um, in particular,
what train def test data
would you collect?
So you've decided on an initial
new inotrope architecture
and you want to train
something to recognize this face.
Robert turned on.
I think there's a pervy I don't think
as possible to download the data set.
I don't think anyone has collected
a data set with the West.
Robert turned on and
posted on the Internet.
So you have to collect your own data for
this particular trigger phrase that you
want to use. But it's um, you know,
as CEO of this thoughts of trying to
build a new and yet to detect the phrase
Robert turned on.
What data do you collect?
Right?
So why don't you take once you again take,
Oh know let's say three minutes
to write an answer to this.
Yeah, I think this is
an interesting one. Um,
Robert turned on over and over.
And then data augmentation,
data augmentation is one of
those techniques that, um, uh,
is a way to reduce,
uh,
in senior learning our room because
you're generating more data and, uh,
having worked on this problem, I happen
to know data augmentation works, you know,
is very useful for this problem.
But if you didn't already know that fact,
this is one of the things I would
probably not do right away because I would
train a quick and dirty system,
validate that you really have a high
clearance problem before investing in the
effort and do data augmentation. So they
only as well as those techniques that,
so, you know, it never hurts
her barely hurts, usually hopes,
but I don't bother to make that
investment unless you have collected the
evidence that you actually have a high
his problem and that this is actually a
good use of your time.
Right?
Yeah.
I think this one that she does
actually nice. So, um, uh,
required everyone to start to Saint
Robert turned a hundred times that really
nice thing about that. You can
get that really quickly. Um, uh,
when I'm working with teams,
um,
I actually think in terms
of hours in terms of hollow
it take us to do something.
So this one you could probably do and
like 30 minutes, right? So get you,
the collected 30 minutes ain't get going
or, or have you run around Stanford,
they just ask, you know, friends or
strangers to speak into your, uh,
laptop microphone.
You didn't spend a few hours together,
much bigger data set then pass with
the startups. I apparently do that.
Probably actually go to collect data
in several hours routing only spend 30
minutes.
But this is actually pretty interesting
as well because unless you get it done
pretty quickly, it makes
sense. Right? So, um,
yeah, so let me actually the uh, uh,
share some more concrete advice. Right.
And I think actually some point sometime
back to prepare a homework problem that
you see later in this course, Ken and
Eunice and I were actually, you know,
building this system partially to, to to
create the homework, right? That, that,
that you see later in
this call. So this is, uh,
this trigger where thing is a nice run.
The example that we're using the few
points throughout this course. Um,
so here's one thing. You can do it.
This does actually what, um, uh,
what we did right,
which is a collect,
I'm simplifying a little bit.
Um,
collect a hundred examples
of uh,
uh,
ten second audio clips.
Great. And so, uh,
it turns out once you grab a hold of
someone and ask them to speak into your
microphone, you know, you can
keep them for three seconds,
which is how long it takes
to say Robert turned on.
Or you can keep them for 10 seconds,
which they're actually very willing to
spend an extra seven seconds of you.
Right? Um, but so if this is 10
seconds of audio data, you know,
so this is 10 seconds of audio and audio
is just patterns of a little changes in
air pressure, right? So if you plot audio,
the reason it looks like this way form,
it's just the way you're hearing my voice
is my voice or the speakers I creating
very rapid changes in air
pressure and your ear measures,
those very rapid changes in the
air pressure interprets as a sound.
And so a microphone, uh, is a,
is a sensitive device
for recording these very,
very high frequency
changes in air pressure.
And this plots there you see an audio
is just what is the air pressure at
different moments in time,
right? But so given a, um,
a ten second clip like this,
if this is the fee second section
where they said Robert turned on,
then what you would like to
do is to build a desk lamp.
Say they can sit here and the lamp
is turned off, turned off, turn off,
turn off, turn off, turn off. And
at the moment they finish saying,
Robert turned on, you know, you
turn it on. So this is a open label.
Why Rooney? Right. And then, and then
it's not detecting the free three.
So. So, so what you want to do for the
trick word system is, um, at, you know,
pretty much the moment they finish
saying Robert turned on, uh,
you want your learning how room to
output a one that's your target label.
Why saying Yep, I just
heard this trigger word. Uh,
and for all other times you
want it to operate zero, right?
Cause cause the one is when
you decide to turn on the lamp,
that moment in time, right?
So to collected data sets, um,
she has something you can do
which is collect 100 audio clips
of 10 seconds each.
And you know,
when I'm prioritizing my work whole,
my teams who are,
I would really look at these numbers and
think, okay, let's say let's say she,
if y'all doing it,
let's see,
you are running around Stanford and you
want to collect a hundred audio clips.
Uh,
uh,
maybe 10 people tend to cliffs for person
or maybe a hundred different people.
Um, I would actually estimate, you know,
if you go to Stanford cafeteria, uh,
how long does it take to get one person?
Right?
And you could probably get one person
every minutes or two if you go to a busy
place out on like a staff,
a cafeteria,
so you could probably get this done in
like a 100 to 200 minutes I two or three
hours. Right? It's not that bad. So
you get this done quite quickly. Um,
and so and and less. He collect hundred
audio clips and Ashley for the, for the,
for the purposes of today,
let's say you collect a hundred
audio clips to use for training
25 for your deaf set
at zero for the test set, right?
It's actually not that uncommon.
If you're building a new product,
they just not have a test set because
you go is to build something that y'all
convinces, you know, just early
prototyping phases of a project.
Sometimes I don't bother with a test
that if it goes to publish a paper,
then of course you need a rigorous,
he collected test that.
But if you're just building a product
and you don't need a rigorous evaluation,
sometimes you can just get started
without dealing with a test set. Right?
So it was pretty well get
started. Um, and then,
all
right,
so taking that audio clip from above,
um, one thing you can do to
turn this into a supervisor,
any problem is to take,
so the phrase Roberts hair can be said
in less than three seconds. So let's see,
you take three seconds
as the duration of audio.
So we can do is a clip out.
So let's say if here was when
Robin turn on them, I said,
so what you can do is I'm
the type of paper that says
why you can do is then it clip out
different audio clips of three seconds.
So here's one audio clip.
You can take that audio clip,
this is x and the target label is zero
because Robert turned on was not sad.
And you can take on all this audio clip
at different band of nature clipped
three second clip and that
clip also has its of a bugs.
Um, and you know, for this one, right,
which is a fee second
clip that, that, that,
that ends at the real,
on the last part of the on sound,
you would have a toggle label of one,
right? So, and, and, uh, when, when,
when you learned about sequence models,
the rns,
you learn a better method than this
explicit clipping. But for now,
let's say you take these, um,
audio clips and turn it into,
so take a ten second clip.
And by clipping out ran different windows,
you can take your let's
say hundred uh clips.
And because for each ten second clip,
you can take different windows.
You could turn this into let's say 3000
training examples, right? So here
I took a ten second clip and, and,
and show you three different
three seconds windows,
but you would take 33 seconds windows.
Then each ten second audio cook
becomes through the examples.
And now you've turned the problem into a
binary classification problem where you
need to train a neural network,
the inputs, a three second clip,
and they balls it as either zero or one.
It doesn't make sense.
And so this is an example
of uh, uh, the, the,
the more complex pipelines you might
have if you're building a learning
algorithm to take a continuous Yale audio
detection problem and turn it into a
binary classification problem,
which you've learned how to bill.
Baer is neural networks for great.
And again, we learn about our nose,
you learn about other ways to process
sequence data or temporal data. Okay.
So, um, oh, go ahead.
Oh, uh, is this Mandy
leaving? Yes, I would. Yeah.
Actually if you have a hundred examples,
um,
is not that hard to just listen to you
on your laptop or some audio playing
software to figure out when,
when they finish saying Robert turned on
and then at that moment to put a one in
to target navel. Right. Cause this is
really when you want the lab to turn on.
Right. Let me see. Cool. So,
um, any other questions? Actually a few
few that ask clarifying questions. Yeah,
go ahead.
Oh sure. Let me get back to
that. Anything else? All right.
Why do we do three seconds
or five seconds? This is
cause another hyper pounds.
You can test. Oh No. Oh yeah.
You had to say it really slowly
to take on l three seconds.
Is this right?
Fizzy Robert Turn
on right? Does it sound okay?
Is it is a design choice? Yeah.
Yeah. Um, all right. So, so, um,
let's say you do this, feed
it to supervisor in the
algorithm, train the new,
and that's where, um, and let's
say that when you classify this,
uh, when, when you run this algorithm,
you ends up with a 99.5% accuracy,
right? Um, uh,
but you find that the
algorithm has zero detections.
Great.
Um, and I what that mean is that
whether the audio you give it,
it just opens zero all the time.
So the algorithm just says, nope,
I never heard the phrase Robert, her
and not, you know, so, so, so, um,
so, uh, and so my question to
you is, you know, and by the way,
the reason I'm going through these
scenarios is, um, I found that, uh,
a good way to gain good intuitions and,
and to become good at making these
decisions is these are the decisions that
project leader write a tech leader,
a CEO needs to make.
These are actually like pretty much
exactly the design she needs to make.
And I find that I'm one of the ways
that this type of experience, if you,
you know, find a job with a good AI team
and work with them for five years, right?
And then you said she lived through
this and you see what they do,
but instead of needing you to go and spend
five years to see 10 examples of this,
I'm trying to step you through
maybe one example in one hour. So,
so instead of, uh, you know, gaining,
does experience through work experience,
which is great, but texts many,
many years, many, many
months hoping to, you know,
let's just put you in that position
and making these decisions,
he comes there and from that
much faster. Right. Um, so,
uh, and, and all the examples I'm giving
are actually completely realistic.
Right there. You either exactly or
very similar to things I have seen in,
in actual, you know, very real
project. So question is, uh,
you're learning our room gives this
result out. 95% of assay zero detections.
Whether you do, let me mention some of
some of the answers I really liked. Um,
I think that, uh, um, you know, I,
when I think of building
learning algorithms, uh,
the process is often specify a depth set
and our test set that measure what you
care about us and then, um,
you don't always have to do it,
but it's good hygiene.
It, it's, it is, um, uh,
Shopkins clarity of your thinking,
right?
If you have a very clear
specification of the problem.
And I think when inside all of
this is that if your desk set,
there's really all the
whack, right? Because it's so
unbalanced. That actress here,
Jeff set doesn't translate to what you
actually care about. Uh, because you know,
presume it is 99.5% accurate
on the deaf set as well.
But this performance is terrible.
So it's doing great on the dead set,
on your accuracy. Mashaikh we're
giving terrible performance.
So I think of it as good hygiene. You
know, this is kind of good sound practice,
uh, to, to just specify,
make sure you at least have a just
said and the validation metric that
corresponds more closely
to what you care about.
So making the depth set more balance,
uh,
equal numbers of positive and negative
with would be a good step to have that.
Um, uh, and then I think,
um, uh, you could also,
uh, there are a few people
that talked about, um,
give the higher weights to the positive
examples, right? So, you know, uh,
uh, one way to do this is the reassemble
your training and your Jeff says to make
them more proportionate.
In terms of maybe closer to a balanced
ratio of positive negative examples.
That'd be okay.
The other way to not do re sampling,
we were just give the positive
examples a great to await, right? Um,
I would probably be re sample. Um,
another thing you could do, uh, uh,
uh, you know, in the
inches of, um, uh, speed,
even if it's not the math,
math most most sound thing to do is to
change the target labels to be a bunch of
ones after that. Um,
uh, and this is a hack.
This is not formally rigorous,
but if you've implemented the
rest of this code already,
this might be a reasonable, you
know, a little bit hacky thing to do.
But this is this, this, this
might work well enough, right?
I, I would, I might not,
I don't know if I would want to try to,
you know,
write an academic research paper with
this method. Maybe I can get away with it.
But this little thing that I think if
you tried to publish the paper with this,
academic reviewers might raise their
eyebrows and say, maybe, you know,
maybe it is okay, but I think of
your one something quick and dirty.
They just works. I think, uh, uh,
they bring the ones changing a
bunch of labels to be one. So that,
say a clip here, right? Uh,
that ends just a little bit after
Robert turned on is still labor one.
There'll be pretty reasonable, but
it still just be saying that, um, uh,
for anywhere within maybe a
0.5 second period off there,
Robert turned on finish.
It's okay to turn on the light
anytime within that period.
Then you kind of want to be turning on
the light, turning on the lamp, you know,
say within half a second right off there.
Robert turned on this has been said,
and this would be a not,
does it be a way to just get
more labels of ones in there?
Great.
Let me say this.
Uh,
how does that translate to like,
when you deploy this,
you're not going to see
Robert Turn Os much, right?
Like one out of 1000 might be
reflective of what you expect to see.
Yeah, this is good. Yeah. Right.
So, um, I think that, uh, put it,
um, so if you actually,
yes, so what I did,
this is how bad deaf set and
evaluation the I show kind
of question, right? So, uh,
one of the couple of the metrics that
people often use a when actually working
on this is when someone says Robert
turned on whether it's the chance that she
wakes up or the turns on.
And then the second is if no one is
saying anything to the lamp, you know,
how often does it randomly turn on by
itself without you having said anything?
So those are the two metrics
people actually use. And, and, uh,
sometimes you could also try the combined
in a single now be evaluation metrical
something. Uh, uh, but
I think that's, um, uh,
you could tend to find a data set
to measure both of these things.
And then and then and then
hopefully finding a way to
combine them into a single
rule number, which I think, yeah, I think
one of the ways we talked about in the,
in the videos as well. Great. So it
makes sense. Oh yeah. But I think,
I think so question is really,
um, uh, what is it? The size,
size is using the right.
Yeah. And Oh and just one,
one thing about the straight forward way
of rebalancing is that if you don't do
this then your whole data set just
as very few positive examples. Right.
Um,
and so if you throw away all the negative
examples so that you cut down the
number of negative examples until you
have exactly equal numbers was a positive
and negatives, you've actually thrown
away a lot of negative examples.
Does it make sense? And so one, one,
one problem with the straight forward
way of rebalancing is that, you know,
and your audio clip and your test ten
second clip they were collected by running
around Stanford.
You have one example of Robert turned on.
And so if you want exactly
PR perfectly balance,
positive and negative, it means that
you're allowed to own the clip out.
One negative example,
all of this,
you can say that's a negative and that's
a positive and Yukon clip out more
negative examples from
this, right? So, so,
so of you use a he of the perfect
rebalance Yara is throwing away a lot of
negative examples that that could be
helpful for them running off. Great.
Um,
so
all right,
so,
um,
you know, a lot of the workflow of
building learning algorithms is um,
uh, building learning Auburn's
feels more light did buggy, right?
Because what happens in a typical
machine or in your work though is you
implement something and it doesn't work.
We'll see you figure out whether is
a problem. So he fixed that. Ah, AH,
like rebalancing.
Are we waiting or adding more once
and so that fixes the current problem.
And then after fixing the current problem,
which, which is the one we just solve,
say you then come across a new problem
and you have to solve that and you to fix
that problem somewhere else. And now
the new problems, I find that, uh,
the workflow of, um, when I'm working
in a machine learning project,
it often feels more like
software debugging, then
software development, right?
Because you're often trying to figure
out what doesn't work and then trying to
fix that.
And after you fix that problem,
then another bug surfaces and the squash
that and you do that and then another,
and you kind of keep doing
that until the offer of work.
So if I keep talking about, you know, your
algorithm doesn't work, what do you do,
nick? Right? That's kind of the theme
of today's presentation, but that,
that is what the workflow,
that is what your day to day work
of developing a learning algorithm.
It's usually like, because it's
like it doesn't work and you fix it,
it still doesn't work. You fix that
and he still doesn't work. You fix it.
And He'd do that enough times
until it works, right? That, that,
that is actually what often working
on the learning algorithm works look,
looks like.
Um,
all right. So let's say
you fix that problem, um,
and you conclude, uh, through
doing error analysis that you're,
our room is over fitting, right? So,
you know,
you've added a lot more ones,
so the Dataset is a
little bit more balanced.
So let's just add a bunch of ones
like I did on that previous board.
Let's just add a lot of ones here.
So the INSEAD isn't as unbalanced and,
um,
let's see.
MMM,
right. Okay, good. Um,
let's say that,
sorry,
two pages of notes here.
Okay, good. So let's say that, um,
you find that are the cheese now,
98% accuracy on training and
50% accuracy on the Dev side,
right? So very lush gap
boutine your training and your,
um, deaf set performance. And
so a clear sign of over fitting.
And so I think one of
the earlier questions,
someone talked about data augmentation.
Uh,
and so we have this clear
sign of overfitting, um,
this is a good time to consider
data augmentation, right then.
So let's say you go ahead and do
data augmentation. So for audio,
this is how you could do data
augmentation, which is, um,
collect a bunch of background,
all audio.
So I guess if you're trying to build a
lab that might go into people's homes,
then you could go into your
friend's homes and, uh, you know,
with their permission record,
right, what the background sounded,
their home looks like.
You maybe people talking to background,
maybe the TV on in the
background, whatever it goes
on people in people's homes.
Um, and then it turns out
that if you take a, um,
say a one second clip
of Robin turned on an Rto and
you add that to background clip,
then you can synthesize an audio clip
of what it sounds like in your friend's
house. If someone were to
suddenly pop up and say,
Robert turned on against the background
sound of your friend's house. Right? Um,
and, and it turns out that, um, uh, uh,
if you want to make the system robust,
so actually phrase apple, they have a,
Oh no,
I actually know someone that lives
unfortunately closely to a train station.
And so their holes as she has a lot of
translation noise from the Caltrain. Uh,
and so when you can do to make your system
more robust is also a take a clip of
safe train noise, right?
Like cow train noise.
And if you take that noise and take, uh,
in, in this case, let's say one second,
one second or three second clip of
someone saying Robert's her and on,
and you synthesize that on top
of the train in the background.
Then once you end up with is a
ten second clip of someone saying,
Robert turned on against the noisy,
you know,
trained in the background
type of debit noise, right?
And so in order to do data
augmentation or data synthesis,
you can take some one second clips that
people saying Robert turned on and the
quiet background.
And then take some one second clip.
But people saying random words, right?
And let's say, you know, Cardinal, right,
since the staffing and synthesize this
against the train noise background.
And then you would have,
in this case,
you would have what sounds like crazy
noise train, train on street noise.
Robert turned [inaudible],
right. And then, uh,
you could generate the
labels now as zeros there,
one's there, and then Zeros there. Right?
Because if this is what it actually
sounded like in a, in a user's home,
then you want the lab to turn on off.
Robert turned on.
But not after these random words, he
can take different random words. Great.
Um, so let's see.
Great.
So,
um,
what I'd like you to do is evaluate,
uh,
three different possible
ways to collect noisy data,
right. Uh, to, to, to collect this
type of background data. Right?
Um, and so, um,
when I like they do for the next
question is let's say you and your team,
you know, have, uh, uh,
uh, brainstormed, um, uh,
uh, brainstormed a few different ways, uh,
to collect this type of
background noise data. Um,
and let's say you've decided that
you would like to collect 10 hours of
background noise data, right? Okay.
So I'm going to present to
you three options. One is, um,
you know,
running around Stanford and
taste microphones around
Stanford or your friend's
house. Do this with consent and don't,
don't, you know, California or shoes,
you're not supposed to. I don't recall
people about their knowledge and consent.
Uh,
second is a
downloads clips online.
Uh, it, it turns out
you can go to youtube.
There are these like 10 hour
long clips of, you know,
rain noise or cars driving around.
And so you actually,
uh,
and again if you do that,
find something that's creative comments
and sort of appropriate with the license.
Right? Um, another thing you
could do is use a mechanical Turk,
Amazon Mechanical Turk.
We can have people over or around
the world, um, be paid, you know,
modest amounts of money to
submit audio clips. Right?
So for the next exercise, what
I want you to do, because I'm,
and I want you that this exercise
of, of, of this discipline,
which is why the why should they
do is, um, I went to the estimate,
let's see what time is it now?
Okay.
It's 12:30 PM very now whether wants
you to do is write down three numbers in
the next exercise to estimate.
If you went to do this,
you know, let's say you were to go do
this right now, right? By what time,
where you have finished. If you were to
do option one, what time would you finish?
And we had to do option two.
What time would you finish?
You were to do option three if you go is
a collect 10 hours of data through one
of these mechanisms. Does that make
sense? So it's tough though. The PM now.
So one of the lecture they do is
just write down three numbers.
First number is what time is it,
what time would it be?
By the time you collected 10 hours of
data, you know, from around Stanford,
what time would it be? Right?
And if you could do this in a so,
so if you think you
would do it by tonight,
then write 9:00 PM if you think it'll do,
if you think it will
take you one the week,
then write the date one week from
now, right? Whatever it is. Uh,
but just write down three
numbers. Obesity activity. Okay,
let's do this one relatively quickly.
You can people do this and like, uh,
maybe a minute and a half. All
right, cool. This is interesting.
Um,
what did people think? Actually this
is a surprising large variability.
I'll mention one thing that surprised me.
Um,
I'll give you my own
assessment. I think that, uh,
you know, w when I'm leading startup
teams, we tend to be very scrappy, right?
And so I think that, um, if it
goes to collect 10 hours of data,
if you have three friends who have laptop,
you can collect three hours of data per
hour cause he goes see recording's going
in parallel. So if I were doing this
with say two other friends, you know,
I bet I bet we could get
this done by tonight, right?
Cause if you need nine hours of data
that each person needs to collect three
hours of data and you run around Stanford,
the Keith and microphones running,
I bet. I Bet I could get this done by
6:00 PM. Right? Maybe, maybe even earlier.
I don't know. Download clips online, uh,
is actually earlier on.
It's actually an interesting one.
Maybe be about the same time.
It turns out one tricky thing about
downloading clips online is that um,
uh, I think a lot of the, you know, there,
there are people that have
trouble sleeping at night
so they listen to highway
noise or whatever. And so
there are these, you know,
20 hours of highway clips,
highway noise on youtube you can find,
but I don't know how
those clips are generated.
And I suspect a lot of them loop right
meaning is the same one hour play over
and over.
So actually think it's harder than than,
than one might guess they get
10 hours of non repetitive data.
And as one of those things,
you know,
if I take an hour of how high sound and
Loopit you can't tell the difference
cause all high res sounds sounds of
saying I just can't tell one minute of
highway sound from another one.
But if you have one hour of highway
sound loop 10 times the learning our room
where she performed much less well than
if you have 10 hours of fresh highway
sounds. So this I will actually have a
harder time doing I think our priority.
I would probably, if I were doing
this I, because of these problems,
I were carried by June until
sometime tomorrow. Right. Maybe,
maybe 9:00 PM or something. Maybe
that's doable. I'm not sure. I'm,
the one surprise to me was some people
thought they could do this by tonight. I,
again,
I've used Amazon Mechanical Turk is
actually a huge process to set up Amazon
where Carl's her get people on board and
especially they get them microphone. Uh,
I don't have your implants something
on flash so we can speak in their web
browser or an and be supportive is,
it's actually,
it's actually not that easy to get a
lot of the Turkers to do this and the
global supply of [inaudible]
salsa unlimited. So I
would, if I were doing this,
I would probably, I know maybe
a week or something, right.
How to say natural.
Um,
but so does specific opinion
isn't that important?
But I want you to go through this
exercise because this is how, um,
efficient startup teams either brainstorm
a list of things and then you all
figure out how long you think it'll take
to do these things. And I think, uh,
you can have a debate about how
high quality the day duress,
I think you can get very high quality
data from this. And from this, uh, I,
I just didn't cuss of those online,
all your sources.
But if this is really fast and you
can get pretty high quality data,
I will probably do this, a collective
backgrounds how to get going. Great.
But I think that part of their
work, so I see of, you know,
fast moving teams is pretty much exactly
what she did, which is why, why is that,
that exercise of brainstorming the list
of options and then really estimating,
oh, what time can we get this done and
then use that to pick an option. Right.
Um, and then I want to just
mention one last thing, um,
which is that
these differences matter, right? Um,
you know,
I've actually put,
I put the last piece of simple all of
machine learning systems, but, um, oh and,
and I think by the way,
if you do everything we just described
and you see this later in a problem set,
uh, you can actually,
with this set of ideas,
pretty much the set of ideas
that we just went through today.
You can actually print the bill, the
bill, a pretty decent trigger words.
It's action system.
I'll wake word detection system.
And in fact we'll ask you to do pretty
much this and the later homework exercise.
But now you know, when you get to that
whore exercise, when you do RNN stuff,
you know how you could come out with this.
So the process yourself,
if you didn't already know how
to make these types of choices.
Oh my, my, my results at the beginning,
I could see like it's not too frozen.
Like my micro lights is the
same as the one that's used. Oh,
when I run the run,
let's mess that up.
That's what we're asked to think about it.
Yeah. So my advice. So what
does your microphone affect
your results? Right? Yeah.
So my advice is put pizza,
get something going quick and
dirty and then develop a depth set,
right with the actual types
of days that you think.
If you get on your role microphone
and then see if it is a problem.
And it may be different microphones,
do you have different characteristics?
And if it is a problem, then go back
and think about how you'd collect data.
There's more representative
of how you test.
I want to mention one more quick thing.
Do I had a heart surveys.
I want us to do something
real quick, which is, um,
I want to tell you why these
things really matter, which is, um,
if this is a performance, right? Oh, oh,
let's say Ashley era and this is the time,
right? And this is today and you had to
see all this thoughts. I remember that.
That's what we're doing.
Just lesson.
And this is six months from now and
this is 12 months from now. Right?
Um, you know, maybe have a
competitor actually, maybe, maybe,
I don't know. Maybe it's because we
talked about this so much in this class.
Maybe two of you in this classical,
I thought the sauce,
but it's certainly a competitor.
But over time,
most of the machine learning teams,
the Arrow actually goes down over time
as you work on problems right there.
That means this is what I see in
tons of practical projects. You know,
you work on the project,
improve the system and the era
as she goes down over time,
as you work on this over the next,
next
12 months, say right, if you're
really see over started doing this.
And it turns out that it's a startups
after discipline to constantly be the most
efficient. Um, don't do something
that takes you two days.
If you can get a similar
result in one day,
the difference is not
that your one day slower,
the differences that your two
x faster, right? And then,
then having that mindset it when take
this whole chart and compress it on the
horizontal axis. Um, then you
want to be the startup
that makes the same amount,
the pros in six months
instead of 12 months. Right?
Because if you're able to do this,
then your startup will actually perform
much better in the marketplace. Uh,
assuming, you know, accuracy's important,
which it seems to be for wake word.
And so don't think of this as
saving you a day here and there.
Think of this as making
your teeth twice as fast.
And that's the difference between this
level, the form. Isn't that lovely?
So that's why when I'm building
teams that execute these projects,
I tend to be pretty obsessive about
making sure we're very efficient in
exploring the options and don't wait
until tomorrow to collect data of dubious
quality when you have a better
idea of collecting data by today.
Because the difference is not that you
wasted 12 hours a different as you had
twice as slow as a company.
Right? So I think, uh,
so hopefully through this example on
your ongoing experiences throughout this
quarter can help you continue to
get better at this. Right. Um,
last thing we wanted to do was, uh, we're
about halfway through the course. Oh,
go ahead.
Um,
we want to handle the survey and anonymous
survey to get some feedback from you
about this costs. And whenever we get
these surveys, uh, we ended up, uh,
uh, thanks to the previous
generations is his feedback.
We've already been gradually
we can cause better.
So I think Ken and I actually
read all of these questions,
I'll cells and try to find ways to
take your feedback to improve the cost.
So I can take, you know, five minutes, uh,
felt the survey and you can hand it in
and just drop it off and on them see up
here in front of me. Very grateful
for your suggestions. Okay.
So,
um,
I think if you haven't
entered your id yet, uh,
you could still do so. But,
uh, that's it for today.
So please start the survey
in the anonymous. You just
drop that back in front,
then we'll wrap up. Okay. Thank you.